[Music]
one of the major major keys we found the
first
high-performing habit is i've never made
a video in a car wash before this is
great so i hit a bottom recently with
this
productivity overload and i realized
that i had to change my patterns
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i
am not a morning person but when you
start your day with an inspiring routine
every day i may be watching these videos
it will
change your life so good morning know
that i believe in you
grab your coffee and get ready for a
shot of espresso from brendan burchard
one of the major major keys we found the
first high-performing habit
is seek clarity and what we found
is one of the practices that high
performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we
had to explain that and later talk about
it in the energy chapter
we had to differentiate between feelings
and emotions and they are different
emotions tend to be
they're the same like we have they're
physical they're almost
always automatic even though when the
brain is creating associations there's
also happen
for us it's kind of emotion comes up
yeah you're watching a movie and you're
just sad and you're like oh my gosh you
know i'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues right you're just like
you know uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make
of what that emotion was and how it
sticks and the meaning we give it to it
yeah and the example i used
you know i like to give and i don't
remember if it's in the book or not
honestly because here's what's happened
this book is 400 pages it was 1481 when
i finished
baby you edited it down yes and it was
1481 good
complete like it was like awesome yes
but i was like that's gonna freak people
out so we're publishing a bunch
in academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
i can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example i like to give is if you
and i go to
a haunted house yeah which i love i love
them i love them and they scare me the
crap but if
you and i walk around you know you walk
around on the walls in a haunted house
someone jumps out at you yeah you and i
are both going to jump yes
we are emotionally going to experience
fright
immediately it's going to be there right
but i might be
freaked out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about
when we start talking about energy
because emotional energy is real yes
and that is look if at six like we we go
to the haunted house at you know 5 p.m
in the afternoon
if at 9 00 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still
feel scared that's not the haunted
house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling that's a
mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow
i'm at my house i've lived here for 10
years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i gotta redefine the feeling i wanna
experience and i work with one
an olympic sprinter gold medalist
olympic sprinter
as a client and this person's huge
breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh
one olympics before not meddling at all
to now gold i said what made like what
was the thing
yeah and one of the things they said to
me was i
learned to define the feeling and i said
what do you mean by that
and he basically said you know if if
if there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect poise and
perfect condition
the one to bet on is the one that says
this is the way i want to feel in this
race right now i know my emotions are
going crazy
like my heart's beating i can hear
everybody i'm waiting for that shot
blast
i can see my goal i know how important
this is and
all these um like their emotions are
there yeah
but that person is defining the feeling
i'm going
to feel centered now i'm going to get
myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all
olympic level com competitors all of
them but they define that
feat that emotion as a feeling that
helps give them a performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel
like nerves he's gonna hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently there is one
feeling one that you're after there's
one feeling
that if you can consistently live and
bring into your life it will
dramatically shift
everything in your life forward your
business your health
your relationships everything if you get
this one feeling
what is it it's your who it's your one
word
it's your most important core value i
talk about this in my book your one word
i talk about this
and build the serve there is one core
value that you have that if you
consistently live that changes
the entire direction of your life and
what's so great about it is you don't
have to remember
18 different things it's one
so for me it's belief my most important
core value is belief
i want to i want to believe more myself
i want to believe in people more i want
to spread more belief to the world
and when i make the best decisions
it's through the lens of belief if i'm
not happy in my life right now
it's because i don't believe enough i
don't have enough belief in myself
in my relationships in the work that i'm
doing i'm not happy because i don't have
enough belief
i've done this exercise thousands and
thousands
of times with people and one it's always
something positive
everybody's who is always something
positive it's always
aspirational it's always towards a
better life it's it's believe or it's
inspiration or it's hope or it's love or
it's family or it's care
or it's extraordinary or it's belong
it's always something positive
and why it's so important to figure out
is because it speaks to the core of who
you
are but there's no one
perfect word for everybody this is the
challenge of self-awareness to figure
out what the most important feeling is
for you that you're after
nina's who was care alex's who was
belong
marks who was extraordinary you know if
you look at alex with belong
that's his who that's his most important
core value if he's ever not happy it's
because he doesn't feel like he belongs
he doesn't feel like he he's spreading
that belong he doesn't feel like he
belongs with himself
doesn't feel like he belongs in the room
that he's in with other people
in the setting in the environment
doesn't feel like he belongs uh
as an entrepreneur if he's not happy
because he feels like he doesn't belong
so his solution is always going to be
more belong
more belonging how do i get more
belonging if i get more belonging and i
spend more belonging
i'll be happier that's the feeling i'm
after and so
how is that practical well when you're
going to you know alex teaches
salsa dancing so if he's going to go
teach a class and he's stressed or he's
nervous or he has anxiety
what does he need to remember so he can
deliver so he can achieve at a high
level
i want people in my class to feel like
they belong
that's all he has to remember i want
people who show up here
my students my customers to have left
to have come to my class and leave
feeling like they belong in this world a
little bit more
and if he remembers to do that he'll
show up as his best self
that won't work for me because belong
isn't my thing i want people to believe
in themselves more so that's what i
think when i'm going into an event
i'm here to serve and i want people to
believe in themselves and their
capabilities more when i'm making this
video i'm going to show up as my best
self
what i'm thinking about i want you you
hello hi
i want you to believe in yourself more
because i know that if you believe in
yourself more today you're going to show
up differently today
you're going to do something different
today you're going to be a different
person today
you're going to be more proud of
yourself today and that's what i
that's my aim every time i'm making
content
so you have to figure out what you're
who is and i walk through the process in
in depth in
in both your one word and build a serve
but let's give a a sneak peek
here right now let's make it practical
because i want you leaping this video
with something tangible that you can
apply to your life and start making a
difference so how do we figure out our
who
to figure out your who you got to think
about what are all the things in your
life that have made you come alive
and some of the questions that i love to
ask are
around past experiences so think about
your parents what did you love about how
your parents raised you
there might be lots of negative things
maybe you hate your parents
or maybe you love love them tremendously
but what do you love
about how they raised you what's one
thing that you loved about how they
raised you
next think about what your favorite
movie of all time is what was your
favorite movie of all time
what is it and then why right why why do
you like that movie so much
it's probably not because of the crazy
action or animation there's something in
the story that you really like
think about your favorite movie right
next your favorite book of all time
what's your favorite book of all the
books that you've read
maybe you've read a million books maybe
you've read four
what's your favorite book of all time or
if you don't like to read what's your
favorite video of all time
look at the videos you've watched on my
channel what was your favorite video of
all time
why who do you resonate with who are the
people that you love
you know eric thomas will yell his way
through everything and oprah winfrey
will hug you through everything and it's
the same
message that they both have they just
have different ways of expressing it
so who do you resonate with and why
what's your favorite book or what's your
favorite video why
what is it about these things that make
you inspired
happy feel loved what is it what's the
common element that's what we're looking
for
one of the most powerful ones is who is
your favorite teacher of all time
and this is one that i ask everybody
anytime i'm going through this exercise
with people
i ask them who is your favorite teacher
of all time
because you've had lots of teachers most
of the teachers you've had
from from grade school for kindergarten
to grade school to
high school to university post-secondary
most of the teachers you couldn't
remember most teachers you've had
you may not even recognize them if they
walk down the street
think about that you just spent how many
months with this person
and if they pass you on the street you
wouldn't recognize them
most of them you wouldn't know who their
names are anymore
but there's usually one to three
teachers that stood out
but one in particular who who's that
person
did they impact your life why are they
so special to you
it's not because they taught you grade
10 french
or grade 7 math right
they made you feel different about
yourself
they made you feel more courageous more
bold like things are possible to give
you hope but
what was it specifically about that
person
so if i if i go through my history
answering some of those questions
[Music]
my parents what i love about them the
most is that they taught me
that i'm evan castrillo carmichael and i
can do anything that i believe that i
can
we're getting a car wash nina's nina's
getting us set up
i look at my favorite movie of all time
it's seabiscuit why seabiscuit
seabiscuit's about this
horse that's too small and a jockey
that's too big and an
owner that has no money and they're in
the middle of a great depression and
they somehow all find each other
and start winning all these races
against the the big horse that
is supposed to win it's big it's got all
the money it got
the jockey the pedigree all of it and
somehow they win somehow seabiscuit wins
and i've seen that movie so many times
and it's a pretty cheesy movie you know
i don't know i think
i don't know that it won any awards
maybe it did i don't know that has the
best acting or has the best
cinematography or has the best storyline
but there's just something about it that
i love
why it's it's belief it's that this
little horse
and this big jockey and his broke owner
could all find each other
and win you know my favorite
entrepreneur of all time
is ap giannini he's one of the five
pictures uh behind me on my wall in my
office in my studio
because he was the believe banker he bet
on people when nobody else would he gave
money to people
based off of a handshake and a look in
their eye he judged the man's character
by
the number of calluses on his hand he
was the first guy to try to lend money
to immigrants
on a mass scale in america because banks
wouldn't lend money to immigrants who
didn't think they would ever pay it back
he gave walt disney the money to start
snow white
his first feature film when at the time
cartoons were these
short two three minute videos at the
start
of a movie people wouldn't want to watch
a full length cartoon what are you crazy
um and well walt disney went to ap
giannini and that was the guy who gave
him the money to do
snow white i love all the stories
i love ap janine it's weird to have a
banker i think is your favorite
entrepreneur but
he was the believe banker he was the guy
who bet on the little guy
he believed in them but nobody else
would and i love that
and then my favorite question about the
teacher
my favorite teacher of all time her name
was madame farr
and she was my french teacher
but she was also my i feel what they
called it
we were assigned in our last year of
high school we were assigned
kind of a mentor personal time with
with a teacher at the school and every
teacher had a certain number of students
that they met with
and most people didn't really meet with
their with their mentor most people
didn't really spend that much time but
madame farr she spent every week we had
time together
every week one of the mornings before
school started
we'd always meet and just talk about
life talk about where i was at talk
about how i was doing in school and how
things were going
and it was in that year that my
standards started to shift
up until that point i was a b c student
i wasn't i wasn't failing i wasn't a bad
student
my sisters always got a's and i would
always get b's and c's
but up until that point i hope that the
sound is okay we're going through a car
wash
up until that point i was a b c student
i met her every week and i don't i don't
remember really
any specific conversation that was so
life-changing
um but i remember looking forward to our
meetings
and i didn't even think it was weird
that we were meeting every week when
when all of my classmates barely if ever
met their
teacher mentors but i remember how she
made me feel
and she made me feel like it was
possible look at this look
look we got look it's coming first round
is the
first round is the soap she made me feel
like it was possible she made me feel
believed she made me feel hoped for me
feel like i could do it
that i wasn't dumb you know
i felt behind i felt like i wasn't smart
enough and she always made me feel like
i could do it and so i look forward to
our meetings
every uh every week and in that final
year
i went from getting b's and c's in all
of my subjects
to getting straight a's
i think it was straight a pluses and it
was in that year that my
yeah straight a plus is 90 plus at 90
plus
in every course in that last year
not because she gave me any specific
instructions she was i mean she was a
french teacher
but because she made me believe in
myself more and that was the year that
my standards to myself rose above
what people around me wanted for me so
my parents
oh look at this look how colorful that
is wow look at that
my parents their goal was they wanted me
to be
an a student they wanted me to be on the
dean's list which was
80 percent in in all my courses and i
never hit it
you know i never got there until my last
year where i got
straight a pluses straight 90s
i think my worst was 90 in english but
straight 90s across the board that was
the year that my standards for myself
rose above what my parents had set for
me
what their expectations of me were from
a positive place like you can do this
that you can do this europe is really
carmichael
i've never made a video in a car wash
before this is great i hope the audio is
coming out okay
and it just showed me how important it
was to have the right people in our
lives
so as i go through that exercise and i
try to find my who
if i look at madame farr if i look at
seabiscuit if i look at ap giannini
if i look at my parents what's the
common theme to all that
the common theme is believe
the common theme is believe believe in
yourself and believe in others
and why this is so important is now i
have a plan going forward
this is the revolution behind your one
word
when you figure out your one word you're
who
it's not just a great lesson looking
backwards it's great to say looking
backwards oh that's why i love that
movie that's why i love that teacher
that's why i love
xyz because i was you're looking
backwards it's not just a
retrospective activity it's actually the
plan going forward
it's that in the future to create a
better life
now it doesn't have to be an accident
for me now i can design a better life
with intention
with purpose what's this what's this
layer nina
just water coating cooling oh cooling
polishing
polishing oh we got the fancy one
polishing
i can design a better life going forward
i know that if if i'm not happy it's
because i need more belief
again need more belief in myself i need
more belief for the people around me
need to inject more belief into the
world
and so you can do the same thing define
the
feeling that you're after the feeling
that you're after is
your who your most important core value
you want more of that
you need more of that and when you
figure that out i think it's one of the
most
important activities that you can ever
do in your life ever
some people get their who right away
we're going through the uh
the dryer now so see how loud it gets
some people get it right away some
people have the self-awareness
and right away they figure out their
who's like this is who i am i know it
and some people it takes them a little
bit of time to go through but
if it takes you two weeks to figure it
out you do the activities over and over
and over and over again look where's
they're going to share the machine
where's the machine
it's coming there it is there's a dryer
thank you dryer grateful for you
if it takes you two weeks to figure it
out i think that's
super valuable because you're who is
with you for the rest of your life
the feeling of belief that i'm trying to
create in myself and others doesn't go
away i'll be a
150 years old still wanting to spread
more belief and still needing to believe
more in myself too
so yes you define the feeling that
you're after
and the most important feeling that you
want to chase forever
is your who is your one word most
important
core value now i've got a really special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action in the next week
when you watch a video and you just get
motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
but when you get motivated and actually
make a plan of action for what you're
going to do
you go from 35 to 91
chance of following through and when you
commit publicly
like in the comments below you jump to
95 chance of following through i want
that to be you
i want you to be the person who actually
follows through so question of the day
is your single biggest takeaway
and your plan of action for the next
week let me know down in the comments
below
so we can celebrate you listen humans
are built to
serve some people are built to serve the
world others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring
to remind you that we're all here to
contribute to make a difference to make
an impact and this
is your field guide for that many of us
have
issues with productivity maybe we are
overly productive but we're feeling
burnt out all the time
or we're not productive at all because
we don't know where to start i found
personally being in business for myself
for the last
20 years that i have been a little
overly productive i almost did too much
and i was
constantly multitasking and making
things happen and just moving
so fast that ultimately i really burnt
out
and i started feeling brain fog i was
feeling disoriented i couldn't focus i
was feeling like
even though i for so many years was
priding myself on the fact that i could
get so much done at one time
i actually don't think i was being
nearly as productive as i could have
been
so i hit a bottom recently with this
productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways
i was then blessed um i said a prayer i
said i need some help with my brain fog
and i need some help with my
productivity issue
and i that day got an email from the dr
oz show asking me to come on and do a
segment with
this lovely author and dr dr mike dao
and me and mike had been in touch many
years for many years just because he
hadn't been authored we were published
by the same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day
i'm like thank you universe you're
giving me exactly what i need
i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling
so chaotic and i'm multitasking so much
and my i feel like i've got brain fog
and i'm forgetting things and
he looked at me says how much are you
doing at one time and i said oh mike i'm
doing a million things at once i have a
thousand tabs up on my screen
and he's like these are big brain
no-no's and they're also productivity
no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask
the less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed
everything for me and his suggestion was
to just do
five things a day to make a list of the
five most important things that i need
to do that day
and not do number two until i've
completed number one
and then once i complete number one move
on to number two then on to number three
and if i don't get through
all five in one day i'll just pick up
the fifth the next day or wherever i
left off i'll pick up the next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things
added on to that list and just be really
committed to that five
task list i did it i started to just be
very clear about the five things i was
doing in a day i told my team
i made a a list in my base camp which is
where we keep all of our notes
and i made it really clear to myself
these are the only five things i'm doing
throughout the day as a result of making
it
super clear and conscious to myself that
i was only going to do five things
i have been more productive i have
created more
have been more intuitive i have been
more inspired
and i've been more creative if you want
more inspiration morning videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there